[Musique]
les mauvais élèves bonjour bonjour cv
dénouement même temps oui alors nous
avons elisa benizio exactement comme ça
que ça se prononce parfait et antoine
richard c'est comme ça que ça se produit
c'est gaza dites moi tous les deux ils
m'ont que votre moitié
exactement de la troupe vous êtes une
troupe oui donc et mauvais élèves
et alors qui manque t-il à l'appel et
vieilli manque bérénice cody oui et il
manque valérie imbert ghosn est d'accord
alors depuis quand existe et vous en
tant que troupes en tant que trop pour
autant qu à tous - oui encore qu'après
ça ferait beaucoup de choses à dire non
à traduire dans non plus n'ont pas
commencé on a créé cette compagnie en
2013 et avant vous avez pris des cours
de théâtre exactement que ça chez on
s'est rencontré au cours jean laurent
cochet à paris on était donc on a
d'abord annoncé d'abord rencontré avec
bérénice et valérian bon et on a
rencontré antoine il ya deux ans et demi
moi j'ai fait j'étais dans un autre coup
enfin j'étais au japon jean laurent
cochet puis après je partais dans notre
cour qui s'appelle le foyer qui sont ils
des anciens élèves profs du cours cochet
qui ont monté ce cours de théâtre et
c'est comme ça un peu que c'est ce
réseau là qui nous a fait se rencontrer
les retrouver alors comment c'est venu
cette idée de monter une troupe une
compagnie que quel est le terme les deux
bras hier les deux ouais parce qu'en
plus c'est un esprit qu'ont
mais c'est de défendre et en fait c'est
venu déjà mes parents donc à leurs
nouveaux parents qui sont ils donc c'est
charles ix dit no way et et en fait
quand j'ai décidé de faire du théâtre il
ya quelques années ils ont soutenu et
enrichi ma décision en mai dans beaucoup
et en soutenant sur voilà les envies
puis surtout le c'est tellement vaste
quand on veut commencer à faire ce
métier donc ils m'ont beaucoup aidé à
dans mes choix et tout ça vous ont
conseillé se consolera pas forcément
jarry connaissez pas grand chose en
cours de théâtre et surtout qu'ils n'ont
pas fait beaucoup
ouais complètement non qu'il soutenait
surtout le le projet de faire du théâtre
après dans les courses étaient aussi et
ils me l'ont dit pour rencontrer des
comédiens et c'est exactement ça c'est
marseille ça a marché
oui vous avez trouvé des affinités entre
vous cap s'imagine wall avait eu envie
de faire un peu le même genre de choses
exactement est en fait le projet c'était
que mes parents tout de suite on dit
bien non vous aide pour montrer vos
spectacles auxquels et c'était vraiment
cet échange là qui a permis à notre
premier spectacle de se monter ça vous a
aidé leur notoriété
ah oui oui violemment bien se battre je
pense que ça rassure jacques ou de gens
mais pour dans la multitude des
spectacles il faut exactement si sa
chance ouais bah oui c'est sûr qu'à
avignon c'est quelque chose qui est qui
qui aide beaucoup d'avoir à la mise en
scène est nue
ouais
tu t'es ok donc vous êtes dit quoi tous
les quatre alors mon ton notre compagnie
rappelons-nous les mauvais élèves
pourquoi
et bien parce que quand on a créé le
premier spectacle on n'arrêtait pas de
se dire donc sortant de secours cochet
qui était très classique oui comment si
on n'arrêtait pas de dire la laci nos
profs voyez ça enfin on est vraiment les
mauvais élèves quoi et on n'arrêtait pas
de le dire on n'arrêtait pas de le dire
et on s'est dit ah ce serait un chouette
non de troupes que de que de s'appeler
les mauvais élèves parce que ça résume
bien ce qu'on fait parce que vous ne
faisiez pas ce qu'on vous avez appris
pas du tout ils sont un peu du tchad
revoilà d'accord alors le premier
spectacle justement moi c'était quoi
les amoureux de marivaux ça s'appelait
et c'était en fait ce que ce qu'on a
récupéré en fait et prix de ce cours là
où est tout de même les classiques
voilà c'est vraiment là l'accès aux
classiques de manière très simple et ça
moi ça m'a beaucoup plu mais c'est à
dire que peut-être que à mon sens
ensuite on les on les garde trop dans
leur coquille et moi c'est pas comme ça
que j'ai envie de m'exprimer mais je le
respecte énormément
mais ce que ça nous a apporté c'est
vraiment la lecture de ces gages à la
découverte exact voilà l'accès et ça
c'était merveilleux pour nous c'était
l'enrichissement énorme de départ et
barbe à tiflet du tout on s'est beaucoup
plus là d'un et en fait on s'est dit bah
voilà nous notre travail c'est de
prendre des classiques mais de les
garder tel qu'elles auront le texte ne
bouge pas d'une virgule et sap ont c'est
très important
et ensuite on s'amuse autour de soi là
on s'amuse et alors vous amuser comme en
bas
avec toute la folie de nos metteurs en
scène et nous on étire un peu ces
situations qui sont des situations
normales et on essaie de retrouver un
peu le burlesque et le et clownesque
dans ces situations qui stagne à ce
qu'une situation de théâtre c'est
toujours une situation un peu un peu
extraordinaire un peu on peut trouver du
clown et du burlesque on prend ce film
là et on le tire on tire on tire on tire
jusqu'à avoir des situations un peu
cocasse et est envoyé un peu le comique
de dans quoi donc vous rajoutez du texte
évidemment voilà en fait entre les
textes classiques
nous on insère des improvisations voilà
au cours des répétitions on improvise
iliad est vraiment comment d'idées des
porteurs me voit et on appelle ça des
intermèdes qui situe entre et ça c'est
vraiment le fruit de nous
improvisation une fois que vous avez
improvisé en répétition la provision
n'est figé continue bien prononcé en
attendant ça même les cris incessants
oui messieurs là on assure le dr la
dernière création la des grands rôles on
avait on s'est beaucoup filmé al'inverse
des deux précédents alors le premier
c'était donc endormi 14-15 c'était
marivaux marivaux les amoureux m'arriver
après vous avez récidivé avec les
amoureux de shakespeare voilà qui est
passée que vous avez joué lors du mois
molière à versailles non non on voit les
photos louis c'était merina super à
succès ah ouais
un grand moment ouais ça chante ça danse
c'est ça oui c'est ça qu'on a un petit
mouradi part à bouira ses spectacles la
cecc en plus d'y apporter donc les
textes classiques et détecte à vous il
ya de la chanson et ça ça nous plaît
beaucoup et c'est ce qui amène aussi ce
côté un peu déjanté un peu fantaisistes
d'accord mais la chance quand elle vient
d'où pardon alors pour marivaux c'était
des chansons françaises que vous avez
été chercher vos gainsbourg et webber
keane bardot reggiani et en fait ce qui
nous amusent essaie de trouver sur les
amoureux de shakespeare c'était pareil
c'est des chansons qui collent
parfaitement aux textes qu'on est en
train de jouer à la situation est donc
c'est ce qui amène aussi pour les gens
une surprise supplément un changement de
niveau exactement une rupture exo pris
exactement et l'inclût finalement
classique dans le mode dans le présent
dans le moderne correctement et où on
peut se l'accaparer
exact et puis c'est tellement des hommes
qui sont intemporels où l'on s'amuse à
l'erreur à les replacer dans d'autres
dans d'autres périodes de l'année ex
pillant et a été emmené dans
l'angleterre des années 60
donc on a des classes donc évident ils
ont été hyper sympas ils ont laissé
chanter leurs chansons
il est un peu les modifier mais les
amoureux de marivaux c'était plus de la
chanson française
en fait c'est des années yéyé un peu
voilà exactement non non c'est pourquoi
mais en fait c'est un peu sur
shakespeare en a vraiment cherché un
thème qui était les années 60 en
angleterre donc toutes nos chansons on
s'y tenait ses 60 anglaise d'accord mais
sur marivaux on avait été moins précis
que ça et on cherchait surtout des
chansons qui marchait avec et on peut
penser pardon au film d'alain resnais le
kiki lequel je sais plus mais qui a
introduit des chansons bas j'étais comme
ça ces personnages là tu sais rien aux
ont enfin bref mais pour moi c'est
surtout de l'asie
j'accuse jacques demy pour manier
les demoiselles de rochefort saddam
n'attend vraiment bon le mois molière
c'est maintenant oui c'est chouette
vous allez présenter un nouveau
spectacle qui s'appelle les grands rôles
c'est pas les amoureux on a pas on
déroge à la règle jamais deux sans trois
nous envient eaux des grands rôles c'est
un long travail et non de laboratoire où
justement donc on est en résidence à
versailles en résidence à la faille voit
la zone jean pierre gérault doux depuis
le mois de novembre est on est on a
installé nos costumes et on a dit allez
qu'est ce qu'on veut faire et on a
trouvé ce thème clé les grands rôles
qu'est ce que ça veut dire les fruits
est ce que ça veut dire
voilà et c'est un peu toute cette
interprétation de qu'est ce que ça veut
dire et donc pour nous ça veut dire des
grands textes ont vu que les tubes un
peu pour aller à l'équipe du théâtre
alors y aura à cyrano roméo juliette
richard trois jours vos attaques
auxquelles vous le texte un touche pas
et des grands personnages
qu'est ce que ça veut dire des grands
personnages des moins grands parce que
c'est ça oui après c'est complètement
sublime exactement rôle peut être en
fait physiquement un petit rôle et sa
course un grand il y en a des comme ça
vous avez un petit nombre
aa oui ah oui il ya des ya des yaka
il ya des surprises quatorze personnages
qui sont tout aussi haut en couleurs les
anglais bouclée et mais ça peut aller
même juste la réplique culte
on s'amusait à prendre juste une
réplique culte et ça a été un grand rôle
oui ça ça peut devenir un grand rôle non
c'est juste c'est juste je parle pas là
de windows c'est vraiment votre propre
perception du grand aux actes mais ça
qui est intéressant
il ya souvent via sa surprise est
exactement ok donc vous allez jouer deux
fois lors du mois molière
vous jouez le
17 dimanche 17 à 17 heures je crois et
après il ya le dan 3,23 à 20h à 20h30 et
vous êtes dans les grandes écuries comme
l'année dernière dont grandes écuries
génial et ensuite alors on part à
avignon enfin oui mais on a l'habitude
martyrs et avignon comme le spectateur
et le spectacle tous nos spectacles
allez jouer depuis 2013 en fait qu'on
fait avignon d'accord et et on joue à la
condition des soies et on va faire
quelque chose qu'on avait fait aussi à
deux ans c'est à dire qu'on va jouer en
alternance nom de ce spectacle un jour
les amoureux de shakespeare un jour les
grands rôles pendant ces merveilleux de
pouvoir aller à avignon avec deux
spectacles qu'on aime
vous avez un qu'on connaît et qu'on a
joué déjà bref voilà qui est rassurant
et un autre qu'on va là qu'on propose
qu'on amène à avignon et et donc les
textes pour de vous le spectacle est
écrit par vous la troupe menée par
charles ix dit non non non il ya une
erreur quelque part donc eux ils vous
mettent en scène
voilà et c'est toujours sur le même
principe donc on a on allait on a les
textes classiques les grands tubes ce
qu'on a appelé les grands pays et entre
entre ses grands tubes là apparaît des
petits moments d'improvisation qui sont
plus maintenant des moments d'un projet
qui sont apparus pendant les
improvisations et
et voilà qu'ils vont qui vont faire ces
genres d'intermèdes entre entre les
différentes grandes tirades grandes
scènes du jeu répertorie ces lieux c'est
quoi votre fantaisie way ah bah oui oui
à la wii shakespeare on suivait là on
suivait la course des personnages ce
qu'on avait pris le songe d'une nuit
d'été donc il y avait l'histoire on l'a
quasiment pas touché là
oui là c'est la palette des plus larges
la page est l'expression est plus libre
disons sur le web et ça promet ouais bon
merci alors bien sûr parce que vous
autres qui vous embrasse également à
l'or ont redit leur nom dé renier ce
coût 10 et valérien dr bonnet voilà donc
aider harry antoine
un grand merci à pas d'heure allait
pouvoir et puis vous êtes en résidence
pour combien de temps deux ans j'ai
envie de dire à l'année prochaine
merci ça vite on va se régaler oui au
revoir au revoir
[Musique]